.
- Bonsoir.
- La crainte des États-Unis
et de l'Europe, c'est de voir
la Chine aider la Russie pour
qu'elle poursuive sa guerre
en Ukraine. Est-ce que, selon
vous, cet échange entre
Joe Biden et Xi Jinping pourra
ou contribuera à dissuader
la Chine à offrir une aide
à la Russie?
- Je pense que oui parce que les
États-Unis, c'est le seul pays
qui peut mettre de la pression.
À son tour, la Chine est le seul
pays qui peut mettre la pression
sur la Russie pour essayer
d'arriver à un cessez-le-feu. Je
pense que même il y a eu des
résultats mitigés aujourd'hui,
Xi Jingpin a fait allusion au
problème croissant du côté
économique et il a déploré les
sanctions qui selon lui pénalise
les citoyens. En plus, à la
télévision chinoise que l'on
commence à montrer des scènes de
la guerre. Il y a un peu de
mouvement du côté des chinois.
- En effet, pour les Chinois, on
avait la version russe, les gens
croyaient que c'était une guerre
comme un impôt protégé.
- On se retrouve là-dessus dans
une position et un dilemme très
difficile. Juste avant les jeux
olympiques, il faut se rappeler
qu'ils ont terminé un nouveau
partenariat stratégique qui va
résister au vent et au marae.
Maintenant, la Chine voit
qu'elle a été entraînée malgré
elle dans une situation qui est
de plus en plus déplorable. Au
même moment comment ce programme
que plus le gardien, plus il y
aura des impacts économiques sur
l'économie mondiale et aussi sur
la Chine.
- La Chine qui n'avait pas p
que l'armée russe éprouverait
des difficultés que le monde se
montre aussi fermement ses
sanctions contre la Russie. Est-
ce qu'il y a de quoi mettr
l'épreuve l'amitié sans limite
entre les deux pays qui avaient
été annoncés de façon solennelle
aux jeux de Pékin?
- Probablement que M. Biden et
tous ceux qui oniiiiiiii
Jingpin récemment ont dû lui
rappeler que l
économiques avec l'union
européenne sont beaucoup plus
importants...
les échanges avec les États-Unis
aussi sont très importants.
Monsieur Biden aujourd'hui a été
très explicite qu'il devait
s'engaàààààààà appuyer la
Russ a a a a a a a a a besoin de
stabilité pour assurer sa
poèèèèèèèèès qui aura
lieu...
- le ministre des affaires
étrangères Sergueï Lavrov en
route vers Pékin aurait fait
demi-tour aujourd'hui car la
Russie... il ne l'aurait pas
fait, faute d'appui de la Chine.
Est-ce que ce sont des signes vt
annoncer un changement
d'attitude face à la Russie et
face à cette guerre?
- Je pense qu'il y a beaucoup da
situation, qui se sent un peupr.
Bien sûr que la Chine et la
Russie ont en commun de se poser
aux États-Unis. Il pense que le
but des États-Unis et de
contenir ses depuis le. Ils
s'aperçoivent qu'il y a des
répercussions. Le problème pour
la Chine, c'est qu'elle n'est
pas habituée à gérer... même si
elle dit qu'elle est une
superpuissance, elle ne veut pas
jouer le rôle que jouent les
États-Unis et elle ne sait pas
comment agir. Je pense qu'il va
falloir l'aider à articuler une
situation à ce conflit.
- Les États-Unis qui pourraient
l'aider à faire quoi, par
exemple?
- Je pense que c'est ça, les
États-Unis ont sans doute
expliqué à la Chine qu'étant
donnée la dépendance qu'on sent
de la Russie envers la Chine, il
y a eu les échanges économiques,
elles ne sont pas importants
autant qu'avec le reste de
l'Europe. Si la Chine mais son
poids est dit qu'il faut faire
des compromis, elle pourrait
mettre de l'avant par exemple
une solution qui consisterait à
établir que l'Ukraine va être un
état neutre dont la ne
pourrait garanti par les Nations
unies. Il reste des grosses
questions comme ça q
avec les républiques du Donbass
et de la Crimée?
- De ce comté, l'Ukraine ne veut
pas... fait in
Chine a parlé d'aide
humanitaire. Quel message peut-
elle envoyer?
- C'est une reconnaissance de la
part de la
besoin de l'Ukraine parce que
l'Ukraine était un fournisseur
très important de blé, d'orge,
de maïs. Là, la Chine se rend
compte que ces approvisionnement
la pourrait être menacée.
D'autre part, l'Ukraine est un
pays très important, la grande
initiative de Xi Jingpin, la
nouvelle route de la soie, à
cause de sa position
géographique. La Chine commence
à penser que les hostilités vont
fafafafafafafafafafafafafafaudra
aider à reconstruire l'Ukraine,
et elle veut entamer l'opération
de se revaloriser auprès de
l'opinion publique.erererererer,
spécifiez qu'il y avait un
accord pour que la Chine
investisse massivement dans les
aéroports et infrastructures en
- Bien sûr, l'Ukraine avait reçt
avec beaucoup d'enthousiasme. Ça
fait parti de la vision de Xi
Jingpin d'étendre son influence
politique et économique en Asie
centrale, en Europe centrale. De
là, aller couvrir le maximum des
pays en Europe. Je pense qu'ilco